O
ANNOUNCING HIS 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
RUN.
WE WILL GET BACK TO THE SPEECH
IN JUST A MINUTE.
QUICK SNAP REACTION FROM PETE
WATCHING WITH US.
HE WENT THROUGH THE FAILURE WITH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND HOW
THIS COUNTRY CHANGED IN THE LAST
2 YEARS.
I GOT AN EARLY COPY OF THE TEXT
JUST NOW.
I AM LOOKING AT IT.
WE WILL GO BACK IN A MINUTE WITH
HIS IMPORTANT CLOSE.
YOUR THOUGHTS SO FAR?
>> WELL, SEAN, NOTHING LIKE THE
ORIGINAL.
HE WENT BACK TO THE THEMES THAT
PUT HIM IN THE WHITE HOUSE FROM
FAIR TRADE TO BORDERS TO ENDING
FOREIGN WARS AND SAYING WE THE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IGNORED BY
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT'S A FORWARD LOOKING SPEECH
THAT RECOGNIZES THE DISASTER OF
THE LAST 2 YEARS.
HE SAID AS PRESIDENT, I
DELIVERED FOR YOU WHERE OTHER
PRESIDENTS HAVE NOT.
THIS LOOKS LIKES TRUMP IN AS
GOOD OF FORM AS YOU HAVE EVER
SEEN HIM.
STICKING TO THE ISSUES THAT
MATTER TO HIS VOTERS AND MAKING
THE CASE TO THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY VOTERS HE IS THE GUY TO
BE THE STANDARD BEARER.
THERE WILL BE OTHERS WHO
LEVERAGED THEIR ASSOCIATION WITH
TRUMP TO GET WHERE THEY ARE.
IF HE STAYS ON MESSAGE THE WAY
HE DOES TONIGHT, HE HAS
A FORMIDABLE CASE TO MAKE TO THE
REPUBLICANS ELECTORATE.
>> GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, WE DECLARE
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THIS WAY.
AMERICA'S COME BACK STARTS RIGHT
NOW.
I KEPT MY PROMISES.
WE ARE A NATION IN DECLINE.
AMERICANS ARE SUFFERING PAIN,
HARDSHIP, ANXIETY AND DESPAIR.
AMERICA HAS NOW BECOME MOCKED,
DERIDED AND BROUGHT TO ITS
KNEES.
COULD YOU HAVE IMAGINED ALL OF
THIS HAPPENING IN 2 SHORT YEARS?
I COULD NOT.
>> SEAN, THE CONSTRUCT OF THE
SPEECH IS PITCH PERFECT.
IF HE KEEPS ON LIKE THIS TONIGHT
HE IS UNBEATABLE IN 2024.
NOBODY CAN TOUCH HIM.
NOT A REPUBLICAN.
NOT A DEMOCRAT.
HE STAYED ON MESSAGE.
ONE KEY THING:  THIS IS NOT MY
AM CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS OUR CAMPAIGN.
HE REMINDED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THE REASON THEY VOTED FOR HIM
ONCE AND TWICE IS BECAUSE HE WAS
FIGHTING FOR US.
HE SAID THIS IS NOT ABOUT
CRITICS AND COMPLAINERS.
HE IS LOOKING FORWARD.
THIS WAS A BRILLIANT SPEECH.
THE BEST IN A LONG TIME.
IF HE STAYS ON THIS MESSAGE, I
AGREE WITH PETE, HE KEEPS IT
BETWEEN THE DITCHES AND THIS
FOCUS, HE IS UNBEATABLE.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO MAKE THE CASE, PETE, HE
TALKED ABOUT INFLATION AND
SECURED BORDERS AND HIS DEFEAT
OF THE CALIPHATE AND ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND HOW PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH WORKED AND HOW
HE KEPT HIS PROMISES.
THEN HE COMPARED IT TO HIGHER
GAS PRICES AND RECORD HIGH
INFLATION.
SURRENDERING ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
AND OUR SOUTHERN BORDER INVASION
AND THE FENTANYL AND OPIOID AND
THE FAILURE IN AFGHANISTAN AND
IN UKRAINE.
MANY PEOPLE OVER THE YEARS,
PETE, SAID THE POLICIES ARE
PERFECT.
DOES HE HAVE TO FIGHT THAT MUCH?
SEND OUT THESE TWEETS?
I AM SURE YOU HAVE GOTTEN THE
SAME QUESTIONS TOO.
IF YOU WERE LIED ABOUT FOR 3
YEARS ABOUT RUSSIA YOU MIGHT BE
DEFENSIVE ALSO.
>> HE HAD TO FIGHT TO GET ON THE
DEBATE STAGE ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE.
TO BE THE NOMINEE.
THEN HE WAS LIED ABOUT.
HE HAD TO BE A FIGHTER.
HE IS THE PREEMINENT FIGHTER FOR
AMERICA FIRST FOR OUR
GENERATION.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
ONCE HE GOT THERE.
HE DELIVERED ON WHAT ANY
AMERICAN FIRST SUPPORTER WANTED.
HE SAID HE WOULD DO IT.
ACROSS THE BOARD HE WAS
COMMITTED.
TOOK THE SLINGS AND ARROWS.
THEY ARE COMING OUT TONIGHT.
THE HEADLINES ARE PRE-I HAVE
BEEN.
HE TOOK THE ARROWS AND
DELIVERED.
IF HE REMINDS VOTERS OF THAT,
STAYS DISCIPLINED AND MAKES IT
ABOUT US AND ABOUT WE THE
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE COMING AFTER YOU.
I AM JUST STANDING IN THE WAY.
PEOPLE WILL REMINDED OF HOW GOOD
THEIR LIFE WAS BECAUSE OF THE
POLICIES OF DONALD TRUMP.
AND PULL THE LEVER FOR HIM.
IT WON'T BE EASY TO BEAT THIS
GUY.
I AGREE WITH GOVERNOR HUCKABEE.
HE IS AT THE TOP OF THE HIS
GAMES HAVING HAD THE RESULTS AND
MAKING THE CASE.
YOU COULD RIDE A WAVE.
THE ORIGINAL IS A FLAVOR IN
ITSELF.
YOU ARE SEEING THAT TONIGHT FROM
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: LET ME BRING IN
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN AND
MONICA CROWLEY.
JIM, LOOKING AT THIS DONALD
TRUMP.
A VERY SERIOUS AND VERY POWERFUL
SPEECH.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S GAME TIME FOR HIM.
>> YES, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
PETE AND THE GOVERNOR HAD IT
RIGHT.
THIS IS OUR CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S THE KEY LINE.
SEAN, I THINK OF THE GREAT
COACHES.
THEIR ATHLETES KNOW THAT COACH
PUTS THEIR ATHLETES INTEREST
FIRST.
THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
DONE FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE BEEN TO THESE HUGE
RALLIES.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A GREAT
LINE.
THE LEFT COMES AFTER ME BECAUSE
I AM FIGHTING FOR YOU.
HIS AUDIENCE KNOWS THAT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS KNOW THAT.
THERE IS A BOND AND RELATIONSHIP
THAT FORMS.
THAT FIRST LINE AMERICA'S COME
BACK STARTS TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
ATTRACTED TO THIS GUY AND HOW HE
FIGHTS FOR THIS COUNTRY.
THEY KNOW HE PUTS THEIR
INTERESTS FIRST AND THEIR
FAMILY'S INTERESTS FIRST AND
AMERICA'S INTERESTS FIRST.
THAT MATTERS ESPECIALLY NOW WITH
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM JOE BIDEN
AND THE LEFT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS JIM JORDAN
YOU ARE GOING TO BE
INVESTIGATING A LOT OF THINGS
THAT HAVE GONE UNDER THE RADAR
FOR THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS.
MONIC IS CROWLEY.
YOUR THOUGHTS BEFORE WE GOT BACK
TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> ISN'T IT REMARKABLE, SEAN AND
JIM, ON THE SAME NIGHT PRESIDENT
TRUMP ANNOUNCES FOR PRESIDENT
THE REPUBLICANS SECURE THE
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK A SEVERE
POUNDING OVER THE LAST 7 YEARS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
IT'S A MIRACLE THE MAN IS STILL
STANDING.
HE HAS TAKEN A POUNDING OVER THE
LAST WEEK OR SO AFTER THE
MID-TERMS.
THIS MAN ALWAYS PUT THE
FORGOTTEN MAN AND WOMAN FIRST.
WHEN HE SAID THAT LINE ABOUT
THIS IS NOT MY CAMPAIGN, THIS IS
OUR CAMPAIGN ALL TOGETHER.
IT REMINDED BACK IN 2016 WHEN
CLINTON HAD A SLOGAN THAT SAID I
AM WITH HER.
TRUMP SAID I AM WITH YOU.
THAT KIND OF FIGHTING SPIRIT FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IT'S NOT
JUST A CAMPAIGN PROGRAMS
ANYMORE.
-- PROMISE ANYMORE.
HE HAS A LONG TRACK RECORD OF
DELIVERING FOR THE FORGOTTEN MAN
AND WOMEN.
HE TURNED THE PAGE ON 2020.
THIS WAS A FORWARD LOOKING
ADDRESS BASED ON POLICY AND
PRINCIPLES AND HOPE FOR
DELIVERING AMERICA OUT OF THIS
HISTORIC CATASTROPHE KNOWN AS
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: JOE CONCHA AND LEO
TERRELL.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS A BIGGER
FAN IN THE COUNTRY OF DONALD
TRUMP THAN YOU.
I AM WATCHING THIS PRESIDENT AT
THIS HOUR.
I AM SEEING A GUY THAT LOOKS
LIKE HE IS DEAD ON FOCUSSED THAT
THIS IS REAL.
>> SEAN, ON YOUR PROGRAM 2 YEARS
AGO I CAME OUT AND TOLD YOU.
FIRST TIME I VOTED FOR
A REPUBLICAN.
HE CARES ABOUT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
RESONATES TOWARDS TRUMP.
THE ABILITY TO DRAW IN THE
CROWD.
THEY TRUST HIM.
HE HAS A RECORD TO RUN ON.
THIS IS A GUY WHO IS VERY
COMFORTABLE IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
TRUST HIM.
I AM MORE DETERMINED THAN EVER
BEFORE.
MORE NOW.
I AM A BIG TRUMP SUPPORTER.
HE CARES ABOUT AMERICA.
AS A CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY I
CARE AND I SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP
AGAIN.
>> Sean: JOE CONCHA THE
PRESIDENT MADE HIS CASE ABOUT
ELECTIONS AND FRAUD.
NO TALK OF THAT TONIGHT.
HE WOULD LIKE TO SEE STATES
EVOLVE TO PAPER BALLOTS LIKE
CANADA, FRANCE AND GREAT
BRITAIN.
YOU HAVE PARTISAN OBSERVERS.
WATCH THE VOTING.
WE HEARD ABOUT THAT POINT.
IT'S ABOUT THE FUTURE BECAUSE
ELECTIONS ARE ABOUT THE FUTURE.
>> THE TONE WAS THE RIGHT ONE.
IT FELT MORE LIKE A STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS AND LESS LIKE
A RALLY SPEECH.
DONALD TRUMP STUCK TO THE
ISSUES.
ALL OF THE CRISES IN THIS
COUNTRY AND IT WAS DISCIPLINE.
HE WAS POSITIVE IN TERMS OF HIS
VISION.
TOOK A COUPLE OF SHOTS AT JOE
BIDEN BUT IT WAS BENIGN IN TRUMP
TERMS.
IT REMINDED THOSE WATCHING OF
HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS
PRESIDENT.
HE OUTLINED THE CONTRAST WITH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
CRIME AND THE BORDER AND FOREIGN
POLICY.
IT WAS WHAT HE DID NOT SAY.
NO TALK ABOUT STOLEN ELECTIONS
IN 2020.
HE DIDN'T ATTACK OR INSULT
OPPONENTS IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY.
THAT'S SMART.
THIS FELT MORE LIKE AN ADDRESS
TO THE JOINT SESSION OF
CONGRESS.
IT SOUNDED PRESIDENTIAL.
I THINK IT SURPRISED MORE THAN
A FEW FOLKS THAT HE WENT ABOUT
IT THIS WAY.
IF HE STICKS TO THE ISSUES, IT'S
GOING TO BE AN INTERESTING
PRIMARY AND GENERAL ELECTION.
721 DAYS AWAY UNTIL ELECTION DAY
2024.
>> Sean: LEO, DONALD TRUMP, I
WOULD ARGUE HIS WHEEL HOUSE IS
WHEN HE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY SUFFERED UNDER